[Applause]
[Music]
man these two economics what Axl Rose is
to the music industry they know if it
rocked in the late 80s in the beginning
of the 90s then they started losing
grounds and nowadays any time they try
to make a comeback the results are
pretty disappointing I know you're
thinking first glance Japan doesn't seem
to be that bad right I mean they have
the video games the anime movies and
world-class tech bear moths
and they're Kara toward Tokyo that looks
like a sci-fi city it's the world's
biggest metropolis with over 30 million
people and they have the fastest trains
the most modern TVs and even human-like
robots nonetheless this country has gone
through two decades without any economic
growth and that's not the worst of it
Japan is the most indebted country in
the world they owe more than twice their
entire GDP and the population is
decreasing faster than anywhere else
which poses a big problem when it comes
to paying for retirement pensions this
is one of the reasons why Japanese
workers have crazy hours and almost no
vacation time and there's good old
technological juggernauts like Itachi or
Panasonic are falling behind the more
modern companies from China and America
just hold on a second because things
they might be on the verge of change yes
I'm talking here about the Tokyo
Olympics do you take place in 2020
[Applause]
it's a peerless opportunity to showcase
their entire country and get the world's
attention yes dear viewer ever since
Japan won the Olympic bid in 2013
tourism has absolutely skyrocketed and
the same goes with private investment by
the year 2020 Tokyo will have 45
brand-new skyscrapers
[Music]
and companies like Panasonic will set
state-of-the-art solar cells in
increasing locations so people can
charge their electric cars anywhere and
if this wasn't enough Sony will launch
their brand-new 8k TV screams yes you
had that right soon enough we are going
to have 8k so you can see every micro
fiber of the athletes t-shirts but hold
on for just a second here because not
everything is so beautiful
you see when Tokyo won the Olympic bit
they had budgeted 6.5 billion American
dollars but since they started building
the costs have doubled and they haven't
even finished yet in fact Tokyo City
Hall is predicted that the total cost
might be up to around 20 billion USD so
the question is are the Olympic Games
actually an opportunity for Japan or
quite the opposite are the Olympic Games
as good for a country's economy as
people say well today we are going to
answer this questions but as we always
do let's take a look first back at the
history
an Olympic fallacy very few things spark
national pride quite as much as the
Olympic Games of course we all like to
brag about the gold medals our country
has but what really in flames patriotism
the most is becoming an Olympic host
[Music]
the excitement it generates is so big
that everyone regardless of their
ideology seems to think that organizing
event for this like the country is a
good thing but from an economic
standpoint things are not that clear in
fact the arguments in favor of hosting
the Olympic Games are a little bit like
how should we say it well there is
inconsistent as a tweet by Donald Trump
according to a paper from the Bank of
Japan the effects of the Olympics are so
positive that they can be felt even
before the Olympics takes place
[Music]
more specifically the same year the
International Olympic Committee named
Tokyo as the host city many started to
see Japan as the perfect place for
investment remember that we're talking
about a paper from an institution as
prestigious as the Bank of Japan this is
basically the Japanese equivalent to the
American Federal Reserve that said one
of their main arguments is that if your
city gets to become an Olympic host the
whole country can join all those big
organizations that every country wants
to be a member of so how about an
example well Barcelona got the
nomination in 1986 and boom that very
same year Spain joined the EU Beijing
was nominated in 2001 and boom again
they joined the World Trade Organization
that very year it seems like this line
of reasoning is pretty bulletproof but
just hold on a second because this is a
textbook example of something called
correlation fallacy in other words the
fact that Spain joined the EU the same
year the Barcelona got chosen as the
Olympic host does not mean that the one
thing caused the other in fact Portugal
also joined the EU in the same year and
they didn't post anything
and the same will happen with China at
the same time other Asian countries
joined the WTO without organizing many
sporting events now just hold on a
second guys I'd probably know what
you're thinking right about now and
you're probably thinking well hey Simon
what what about other international
attention that the Olympic Games can
bring I mean for two whole weeks the
whole world is going to have their eyes
on Japan that's got to be a good thing
right I mean we're talking about the
biggest sporting event in the world well
maybe not you see the London Olympics in
2012 got a pretty average audience I
mean around 31 million Americans tuned
in to making comparison this is twice as
much as an episode of Game of Thrones
and that wasn't exactly be regarded as
bad but what about the rest of the games
now the Sochi Olympics in 2014 didn't
even have 22 million viewers in the
United States and Rio in 2016 well I was
just 26 million so now these numbers
might look quite big to you right now
but it's really nothing if we compare it
to a much cheaper events like the Super
Bowl the 2016 Super Bowl surpassed a
hundred and ten million viewers in other
words even though the Olympics are
watched all around the world when you
look at the audience country by country
the figures aren't really that
impressive and this means that the
perception people have about a country
doesn't really change least it doesn't
really seem to change for too good a
study of the impact of the 2000 Olympics
in Sydney Australian researchers
interviewed people one year before and
after the games they found little change
in perceptions with one surprising
wrinkle South Africans were displeased
with Australia because of the way in
which the Aboriginal issue was
highlighted and portrayed by the South
African media
nonetheless there is one thing that it
seems fair to agree on olympic games do
kickstart your tourism industry actually
since tokyo was chosen as the Olympic
host tourism in Japan is absolutely
skyrocketed I mean they almost didn't
have any tourists in 2013 but last year
they surpassed 24 million people you
could say that essentially a brand new
industry has just been born in Japan and
tourism well tourism is an industry that
attracts a lot of foreign money and for
our money I mean gotta be a good thing
right well I can't just hold on a minute
because even these figures they're up
for debate
of course tourism in Japan it's
increased a lot but do you know of some
other countries that also have a booming
tourist sector right now
well Chile and Thailand are great
examples they have grown at a similar
rate to Japan and don't even google it
because I'm gonna tell you right now
neither of these countries is planning
to host the Olympic Games anytime soon
[Music]
the Thailand's example is pretty
paradigmatic they get six million more
tourists than Japan each year and they
have just half the population and their
tourism growth is directly correlated to
that of the Chinese middle class in
other words as Chinese people have more
money they want to do more sightseeing
and well where do they go
well they go to countries that are
nearby and have beautiful things to see
alright alright so now you might be
thinking well even if the Olympics
aren't as profitable as they seem well
what's the problem if Tokyo wants to
host the Olympics I mean him doesn't
like having a Giants Stadium in his city
well let's have a closer look at that
one too
[Music]
old medalist in spending now we all know
that the Olympics aren't costly from one
day to the next Tokyo basically went
from not having to have an Olympic
stadiums or having to have one which has
to hold more than 80,000 people and also
I mean they have to impress everyone
with lights and colors and all sorts of
fancy things but it doesn't stop there I
mean they also need other special venues
for the many competitions that are held
at the same time each of the sports has
its own specifications in total 31
venues will need to be built or
remodeled for the Tokyo 2020 Summer
Olympic Games and then there's the media
center another giant white elephant
sends on top of anthers the olympic
villa the olympic villa is basically
nothing short of a small town where
10,000 athletes are going to live during
the Olympics and you can probably
imagine this is certainly not going to
be cheap now remember the total cost for
this was supposed to be 6.5 billion USD
at least this was the figure given by
the local authorities to the
International Olympic Committee in 2013
but as you know theories are one thing
and reality is something completely
different Tokyo 2020 Olympic Games costs
just keep rising by December 2017 Tokyo
City Hall had already spent over 12
billion dollars and just a couple of
months later the local authorities
reported that they would end up spending
that whopping figure of at least 20
billion dollars and it's even possible
that this figure will keep rising before
they even begin to burn the Olympic
flame but I mean none of this is really
a surprise since we can remember every
Olympic game has had significant cost
overruns
[Music]
rio de janeiro 2016 ended up costing 51
percent more than expected but the
record so far is montreal 1976 which
cost seven hundred percent more than was
initially budgeted you heard that right
eight times more than what was first
planned alright so now you might be
wondering well all these billions of
dollars really all that much money for a
big government i mean compared with
normal spending in a big city hall is
that actually a lot of money well the
answer to that is an absolutely
resounding yes for better understanding
with twenty billion u.s. dollars you
could build a highway that connected the
extreme north of japan to the extreme
south and that really isn't even the
worst of it
[Music]
you see an airport or a highway can end
up being a waste of money but still you
can always reuse Eliza's a country with
better infrastructure and communication
can have better companies in the future
brand new industries a better public
services what you get with an Olympic
Stadium that can host 80,000 people well
if we look at past examples the answer
to that question is pretty bleak Rios
Olympic venues already falling into a
state of disrepair the rio de janeiro
example is particularly harsh
despite hosting the Olympics they still
have entire neighbourhoods that aren't
even connected to the city center by a
bus line and the place where the olympic
villa was unless becoming a slum and
this is not the only example athens
olympic site in ruins ten years on from
the 2004 games and then you've got to
add to all of this that japan is the
most indebted country on the planet they
owe a some equivalent 230 percent of
their GDP the government is already
struggling to pay retirement pensions
and they've already been two years
without any economic growth whatsoever
[Music]
but now now it's over to you do you
think the Tokyo Olympics in 2020 will
mean the ruin of Japan or maybe against
the odds do you think Japan will benefit
from hosting the event well please leave
your answer in the comments section
below and if you want to know more about
Japan's failed economy please do click
on this video also do visit our friends
from the reconsider media podcast go to
reconsider Mediacom this podcast
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine and don't forget that we
publish brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday just like this so hit
that subscribe button and you won't miss
a single post also if you like this
video please do give a thumbs up and as
always I'll see you in the next one and
if you want to learn more about politics
and hear more of my lovely voice don't
forget to check out the reconsider
podcast at reconsider Mediacom
[Music]